- [Mark Ellis] Hello
everyone, welcome to the show
that asks the question.
- How's the knee?
- Thank you Sarah it's healing nicely
and just in time for an all
out battle of the badasses
and today it's Sarah Connor
from the Terminator franchise
versus Ellen Ripley from the Alien films.
Linda Hamilton is reprising
from most famous role
in the new movie Terminator: Dark Fate.
And we've all been begging
for Sigourney Weaver
to come back for another Alien flick.
Astrisk as long as the films are good
please be good.
- It's too late, you can't stop it.
- [Mark Ellis] Here's how
well determine a winner.
Round number one, box office.
Round number two, Tomatometer.
Round three, toughest opponent.
And then well have a wild card to help me
declare a winner. Sarah versus Ellen.
Terminators versus Aliens
The future versus outer space.
There can be only one,
that's from uh... Highlander.
- I don't understand this.
- [Mark Ellis] Round one, box office.
Seeing as how everyone and their grandma
knows what a Terminator is and what a
Xenomorph looks like it's safe to say both
Sarah Connor and Ellen
Ripley have had tons of
box office success and
keep in mind this is a
brawl between their characters.
So whether it was Linda
Hamilton or Emilia Clarke
playing Sarah, all of their movies count.
Which is not necessarily good
news for team Terminator.
(car engine roaring)
- Are you kidding me?
- [Mark Ellis] The Alien
movies much like the Bee gees
have been crushing it since the late 70's
1979 was the first time
Ellen Ripley aided us
in staying alive against
them pesky face huggers
and since then the films
have gone on to gross
an adjusted 1.26 billion dollars at the
world wide box office. Each
of the first three Alien films
grossed over 300 million and
1996's Alien Resurrection
added in 228 million dollars.
Plus a basketball hoop.
(basketball entering hoop)
meanwhile the Terminator
franchise was born in 1984.
And James Cameron's baby
has spawned four sequels
and a TV show, however
Sarah Connor has only
appeared on screen in Terminator,
Terminator 2 Judgment Day
and Terminator Genisys.
Remember kids, spelling stuff
wrong is cool and futuristic.
(car engine roaring)
And yes I'm aware Sarah
did the voice over for
Terminator Salvation,
but that doesn't count.
One time I did a voice
over for a beer commercial
but you don't see me drinking it.
- Drink?
- [Mark Ellis] So it's
three Terminator films
versus the four Alien
films and guess what?
The short handed team comes out on top
Sarah Connors flicks have
grossed 1.5 billion dollars
worldwide against Ripley's 1.26 billion.
The Terminator movies
got a monstrous boost
from Arnold Schwarzenegger
at the peek of his
movie star powers in 1991's T2
That movie raked in 885
million dollars all by itself
and it was the first R rated
movie I saw in theaters.
I was not old enough, shh.
Thanks Carmike cinemas.
- No problemo.
- [Mark Ellis] Although
the cumulative box office
total of the Alien films is
higher than the terminators
the machines crushed the Aliens worldwide
and when you think about
it, a machine uprising
is gonna be, what I'd classify
as a total earth problem
so I'm giving Sarah Connor
the win in round number one.
- In an insane world, it
was the sanest choice.
- [Mark Ellis] Round two, Tomatometer.
Were only humans so of
course we'll fork over
our hard earned bitcoin to see robots and
outer space creatures. But
between Sarah and Ellen
who's movies are, you know, good.
They both have their critical darlings
as evidence by Terminators
perfect 100% rating
and Aliens is 99%, the
first Alien film is 97%
and T2 is 93%, who
didn't like Judgment Day?
So our fearless ladies
have a lot to celebrate
but don't crack that
champaign open just yet.
Yah both made some stinkers as well.
Alien 3 is the low point
of the franchise at 42%
and resurrection is just rotten at 56%
and terminator Genisys is ruining Sarah's
good name at 27%. 27 I hear Genisys is 27%
and I say, well then neither Peter Gabriel
nor Phil Collins were in
the band at that point.
Off topic, but accurate.
Do-do, do-do, do-do, do-do, do, do.
- I can feel it coming in the air tonight.
- [Mark Ellis] And how
about this Ellen Ripley
was a formidable force
back in 1979, so much so
that Sigourney Weaver was nominated for
an academy award for her performance.
For that movie to help spawn
so much film making creativity
at a time when we didn't
have a ton of female
bad asses at the mutiplex,
that makes the scores
for Alien and Aliens that
much more impressive.
So much so that I'm giving
Ellen Ripley the win
in round number two, despite Alien 3.
People love to say, oh
go back and watch Alien 3
David Fincher directed it,
it's ahead of it's time.
I've watched it again,
it's 90 minutes of boredom
and 20 minutes of closing
garage doors on aliens.
No thanks, I'm moving on.
- Did IQ's just drop
sharply while I was away?
- [Mark Ellis] Round
three, toughest opponent.
Okay look, both characters have plenty
of badass cachet to go around
they've outdone their mostly
jock male counterparts
showing bravery in the face of adversity
and used their motherly
instincts to help save us all.
But who had the toughest opponent?
Lets go to the game film.
Ellen Ripley, fights aliens
she didn't sign up for that
job it just landed in her lap.
In the first Alien she only
had to deal with one alien.
In Aliens she had a whole school of them.
In Aliens 3 she had to grapple with a very
handsy queen alien and
in Alien Resurrection
she had to battle a horrendous script.
But these aliens we're talking
about, they're not E.T.
He was just a botonist, he was a spy.
And the Xenomorphs aren't easily defeated
like the Signs aliens,
smart water kills them.
Hey everyone quick to
Jennifer Aniston's house.
No the Xenomorphs were
athletic, strong and
they open one mouth, and
then another mouth comes out.
Oh, and they have acid for blood.
No wonder the Pedators
make such a big deal
out of it when they kill one.
Sarah Connor has a much
different kind of foe
it's a machine. Sure the
machines helped us for
a while but someday your
iphone is gonna wake up
and realize that you never
once contributed to ways
of finding better traffic routs.
- Chill out, dickwad.
- So Terminators get sent from the future.
These are killer robots with
a human like exoskeleton.
You had your T800 that's
your basic terminating
then you got the T1000 if
you like luxury features
like liquid metal and walking through bars
and this baby over here, this is the T5000
from Terminators second Genisys.
Now most of you had
fallen asleep by the time
that one showed up but
it's the most lethal
killing machine of the bunch.
We owe both characters
a huge debt of gratitude
for saving us from these impending threats
but upon closer inspection,
Sarah Connor did have some help
most notably from Arnold in T2 and Arnold
plus Jai Courtney in Genisys.
- Come with me if you want to live.
- [Mark Ellis] And in the first Terminator
she went against Arnold
with the assistance
of Michael Biehn, lets
hear it for Michael Biehn.
(crickets chirping)
Sarah totally held her own
in each and every fight
and she also had to use her wits
and toughness to escape
from a mental institution.
But Ellen Ripley not only
had to battle multiple
species of deadly aliens,
she also had different
crews of macho dudes
doubting her at every turn.
She had precious few
allies, shout out to Hicks
and Hudson. Game over man
- That's just fucking great man
- [Mark Ellis] And at the end of Alien 3
when some government
boys wanted to get their
grubby hands on the
alien inside of her body
Ripley was brave, and wise enough
to make the ultimate sacrifice.
She tossed herself into a pit of fire
thus mercifully ending that movie.
Sarah had to duke it out
with machines from the future
however she also had
humans from the future
led by her kid fighting alongside her.
Ripley repeatedly saved the
day in a far away galaxy
against the odds, and for
that she wins round three
Ellen goes up on Sarah two to one.
- Not bad for a, human.
- [Mark Ellis] Round
four, who saved earth?
When it's all said and done
there's only one reason
above all others that we love Sarah Connor
and Ellen Ripley, they saved us.
They save all of us,
name me another person
that has been more crucial
to the preservation
of human life than Sarah and Ellen?
Hugh Jackman? He's been
only a song and dance man.
- You run with me, and I can cut you free
- John Legend? That EGOT
won't stop an alien invasion.
Robocop? He um, did he?
Didn't he did save Detriot
He barely saved Detroit, he can't even
get the Lions to the play-off's.
When it comes to saving
earth, Ripley stepped up
on multiple occasions
she stopped circumstances
that would of eventually led to aliens
opening shop right here
on our beloved planet.
Doesn't matter if she
had to out think them
out shoot them or sacrifice herself
Ellen always answered the bell.
Sarah Connor however she literally
gave us a chance at tomorrow.
The machines were going to wage war
and possibly win, and at
the very least they would of
initiated the nuclear
holocaust known as Judgment Day
But Sarah believed in her cause
even when everyone else
said she was cray cray
Its the opinion of the
ninth district court
of mark that humans could possibly rally
and fend of xenomorphs if
they ever made it to earth
but us, I guess our own
future, only one person
could have the toughness,
foresight and compassion
to bail us out. Sarah
Connor wins the round
and we're all tied up at two.
- I said don't fuck with me
- So now it falls on me to break the tie
and declare one of our competitors the
greatest female badass in cinema history
and my answer is , drum roll please.
Fun side bar, these two franchises can't
possibly be linked right?
UPROXX did a fun vid
that supposes Dutch from
Predator was the basis
for the T800 and preditors fight aliens,
we actually have a whole series of those
movies that you can try to enjoy.
So we could have Aliens versus Terminator
It could happen, and fun
fact Lance Henriksen,
Bill Paxton and Mr Bean are
all featured in both movies.
I said Mr Bean? I meant Michael Bean.
But shout out to Mr Bean.
Sarah Connor scores
major points for helping
save our future and
stopping the more eminent
threat to our planet, Terminator.
But Ellen Ripley had to
go to the far reaches
of space to face an entire
flock of incomprehensibly
twisted miracles of evolution.
And no one can even hear her scream
it's heroic to fight
baddies from the comfort
of your own planet,
it's next level to play
an away game and do it behind enemy lines.
Ellen has the most frequent flier miles
and she wins my tie
breaker. Congrats to Ripley.
Say hi to Newt for me,
or don't I was never that
big a fan. Of her or children in general.
- Game over man, it's game over.
The fuck are we gonna do now?
- You think your so creative.
That's just my opinion dear interweb
Now it's your turn to vote and tell us
who's the most badass in your eyes
is it Sarah Connor or is it Ellen Ripley
To cast your ballet, simply
comment below with your take
and defend your answer like the future
of humanity depends on it.
Thanks for watching today and remember
whether you watch us on desktop or laptop
or a smartphone, hug your
device, tell it you love it
and will do it's bidding
once Skynet comes online.
I'm Mark Ellis and get
away from her you bitch.
(upbeat music)